entre abucheos y vítores en la cámara de
los comunes
el ministro de finanzas Jeremy Hunt
anunció un plan fiscal de más de 62.000
millones de euros para lo que denominó
una situación de emergencia en Reino
Unido que ya está oficialmente en
recesión
la oficina de responsabilidad prevé que
la tasa de inflación en el Reino Unido
alcance el 9,1% este año y el 7,4% el
próximo confirman que nuestras medidas
actuales contribuirán a que la inflación
caiga bruscamente a partir de mediados
del año que viene
también sostiene que el Reino Unido al
igual que otros países está ahora en
recesión la situación económica del país
y del continente es peliaguda y El
Ejecutivo de rishizunak la quiere paliar
con un plan presupuestario que incluye
más impuestos a ciudadanos y compañías
energéticas y mayor austeridad en el
gasto público los británicos con
ingresos equivalentes en libras a más de
143.250 euros anuales tendrán que pagar
un 45% en impuestos sobre la renta
rebajando el umbral previo de 170.000
euros
impactaría a unas 2,6 millones de
personas las empresas que generan
electricidad tendrán un impuesto
temporal del 45% sobre las ganancias
extraordinarias que les está generando
la guerra en Ucrania mientras que las
firmas de petróleo y gas deberán subir
del 25 al 35%, el impuesto sobre sus
beneficios esto hasta marzo de 2028 todo
con un objetivo recaudar dinero e
intentar a mejorar la calidad de vida de
los británicos
yo pondría primero un impuesto a los
ricos así de simple y trataría de dar un
poco de alivio a la seguridad social y
de Volver al Estado de bienestar del
país todo lo que han estado quitándole
por 20 años
con el 11,1% interanual en octubre la
economía británica enfrenta la inflación
más alta en 41 años